We'll start with a pattern of a counter. That pattern teaches us to make an
integer variable that counts whatever it is that we want to count. You want to
have another method that increments the counter when whatever interesting event
happens that you're counting. And you'll usually want a method that returns the
current counter value so that the user of the class can get at it. Okay, that's
all really abstract, so let's look at a concrete example. Here, I have the
beginning of a Car class. A car has a given number of seats. That of course is
not my integer counter, because that number doesn't change. And then I have a
method here called addPassenger. Whenever that method gets called, another
passenger enters the car. And then I have a method for counting the number of
passengers in this car, not counting the driver. What I'd like you to do is,
use this pattern and add an instance variable for the counter, which you can
call anything that you think is appropriate. And to implement the methods that
increment the counter and that returns current value.